اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام مباشره الى هذه
الصور التي تصلنا من فلوريدا الامريكيه
لوصول رائدي الفضاء السعوديين علي القرني
وريان برناوي
وهما رائد الفضاء اللذان سينطلقان في
المركبه دراغون وتحمل الصاروخ فالكون
التسعه وعلى متنه اربعه رواد فضاء اضافه
الى السعوديين هناك رائده فضاء اخرين
وسنتابع اخر التفاصيل مع هذه الصور تصلنا
قبل ساعات من انطلاق هذه الرحله التاريخيه
معنا حسين الطاوود مراسل العربيه من هناك
اهلا بك حسين ما اخر المعلومات
تحيه لك طاهر بالفعل هي لحظات تاريخيه
طموحه في الحقيقه الان انا امام طائرتين
منتظرين لخروج رواد الفضاء ليلوحوا
قبل ان يستلمهم فريق سبيس اكس لاجراء
التحضيرات واللمسات الاخيره قبل
ذهابهم الى
الصاروخ بمعنى سيفحصون البذات الفضائيه
التي يرتدونها وهي بالمناسبه بالذات خاصه
لهم الان يلوحون لنا وهم يخرجون هؤلاء
رواد الفضاء على يمين ايضا هناك اهالي
هؤلاء الرواد فئتين الطائرتين كما قلنا
اربع رواد فضاء اثنان امريكيان واضافه الى
[موسيقى]
في الطياره الامامي الاولى ارى علي مع
رائد الفضاء الامريكيه في الطائره الاخرى
ريانه مع رائد الفضاء جون شافنير والرائده
الامريكيه في هذه الطائره التي امامي
والتي تخرج الان ربما
هيتسن كما قلت طاهر هي لحظات تاريخيه في
الحقيقه
قبل عمليه الانطلاق عندما تحدثت الى
المسؤولين في اكسيوم قالوا لي بان هناك
الان اجراءات لمسات الاخيره هي لمسات
روتينيه مثلا كيفيه لبس البدله الفضائيه
الخاصه لكل من الرواد
4 يخرجون من نفس الطائره في الحقيقه علي
الجرني ريان واضافه الى
هؤلاء الرواد سياخذون الان بعد تقريبا
ثلاث ساعات او اربع ساعات ونصف مغامره فض
بنكهه سعوديه عربيه هذه المره يقتربون
منها طبعا سيكون هناك مسافه محدده سيقفون
عندها الان حسب ما فهمنا بسبب الحجر الصحي
الذي التزموا به لمده اسبوعين تقريبا لن
يقتربوا كثيرا من اهاليهم اهاليهم الان
على يمين الشاشه يسلمون عليهم يتكلمون
ساحاول ان اقترب مع المسلمين المصور لنرى
الاهالي اذا امكن هم على يمين الشاشه كما
قلنا طاهر هم ملتزمون بهذه المسافه بسبب
الحجر الصحي الذي كانوا به كي لا يتم لا
قدر الله حدوث اي عدوى كانوا محجورين لمده
اسبوعين
الان سيستلمهم من هنا فريق سبيس اكس هؤلاء
الاهل الذين نراهم امامنا الان من المملكه
العربيه السعوديه طبعا اضافه الى اهالي
رواد الامريكيين نذكر الرواد الامريكيون
هم
رائده الفضاء اللذاني سيقودان
المركبه مركبه دراغون نبقى مع الصوت
الطبيعي
اذا نشاهد واياك حسين والمشاهدين الرواد
الاربعه اثنان منهم سعوديان واثنان
الاخران امريكيان وهما يحيي وهم يحيون
اهاليهم ووسائل الاعلام التي اتت في تغطيه
لهذا الحدث الكبير حدث تاريخي
بمشاركه رائدي فضاء سعوديين هما ريان
برناوي
ونشاهدها بوضوحها في هذه الصور وهي تحيي
اهلها ووسائل الاعلام قبل ان تنطلق مع علي
القرني الذي نراه ايضا الان مع رائدى
الفضاء الامريكيين ضمن طاقم المهمه
الفضائيه في محطه الفضاء
بالفعل طاهر هي لحظات حماسيه لحظات فيها
الكثير من المشاعر لهؤلاء الرواد هي تجربه
فريده وخطوه عملاقه من اجل تحفيز الشباب
على الاهتمام اكثر بعلوم الفضاء هذا
البرنامج هو برنامج طموح
يعمل على زياده راس المال البشري بالنسبه
للمجال مجال الفضاء هذا هو الهدف الهيئه
هي السعوديه للفضاء الان نراهم يبتعدون
قليلا هذه هذه الصور الان
لوسائل الاعلام
خاصه وان يعني هذه الرحله سينتج عنها
تجربه بحثيه علميه رائده حسين في الجاذبيه
الصغرى نحن نتحدث عن اربعه عشره تجربه
بحثيه منها حاله انعدام الوزن في الفضاء
وتلك الابحاث ستعزز بدون شك بنتائجها
مكانه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
في مجال استكشاف الفضاء وخدمه البشريه هذه
التجارب ستشمل الابحاث البشريه وعلوم
الخلايا عمل الامطار الصناعيه في الجاذبيه
الصغرى
وايضا تركز بعض هذه الابحاث على عمل
الامطار الصناعيه اذا من خلال تكثيف بخار
الماء على العوالق الجويه وذرات الملح في
الجاذبيه الصغرى ما يحاكي عمليه البذر
السحابي التي تستخدم في السعوديه والعديد
من الدول لزياده معدلات هطول الامطار اذا
نحن نتحدث عن تجربه فريده من نوعها بخصوص
السعوديه العالم العربي
وكذلك بالنتائج التي يمكن ان تخرج بها بعد
البدء بالاستفاده من هذه الابحاث التي
يقوم بها رواد الفضاء الاربعه
بينهم طبعا رائده الفضاء
السعوديان علي القرني وريانه برناوي نسمع
لصوت الطبيعي
نعم حسين اذا الان يتجهون نحو سياره
نعم ايضا هذا البرنامج طاهر يهدف الى
تاهيل كوادر لخوض رحلات فضائيه طويله
وقصيره المدى
والمشاركه في التجارب علميه ايضا كما تقول
الهيئه هي تهدف لبناء راس مال بشري وطني
سعودي ليكون رافضا اساسيا لصناعه الفضاء
وهذا ياتي ضمن اطار رؤيه
2030 هو برنامج طموح يهدف الى تحفيز
الشباب وايضا الاجيال الصاعده للاهتمام
اكثر بالبحوث العلميه وخاصه في مجال
الفضاء وهذه ليست الخطوه الاولى التي
تخذها المملكه العربيه السعوديه يجب ان
نذكر انها ايضا وقعت على اتفاقيه ارتمس
لاستكشاف والاستفاده من القمر والمريخ
والكويكبات هذه هي السيارات التي ستنقل
الرواد الفضاء
ستنقلهم الى المركز حيث سيتم كما قلنا
اجراء التحضيرات واللمسات الاخيره مثل
ارتداء البذات وفحص البلدات الفضائيه
ونذكر بان كل بلذه فضائيه هي مخصصه لكل
واحد من هؤلاء الرواد خصصت له لكي تناسب
جسده سيفحصونها كلها جرى لربما بعض
الاجراءات الروتينيه الاخيره قبل ذلك كنت
تحدثت الى موظفين في اكسيوم اثنان قالوا
لي بان الرواد تناولوا وجبات وجبه الغداء
قبل قليل وجبه خاصه اجروا فحوصات اخيره
الهيئه الفضائيه السعوديه كانت تحدثت
البارحه اعلنت ان الاجراءات الاخيره لهذه
العمليه عمليه اطلاق الرواد
ذهاب الرواد الى
المحطه الفضائيه كانت انتهت البارحه ولكن
هناك اجراءات روتينيه عاده تسبق اللحظات
الاخيره هم يلوحون الان يودعون اهاليهم
على امل العوده بخير وسلامه ان شاء الله
طبعا بالنسبه للاهل لحظات كبيره ايضا نعم
نعم
علي علي الله معك ريانه
مشاهدين الاخباريه
المشاهدين
نعم الان نودعهم
تمام
الله معكم الله يعطيكم العافيه شكرا شكرا
هي لحظات يعني انا طاهر كنت تحدثت الى بعض
الذين اشرفوا على تدريب ريانه وعلي في
تكساس اخبروا اخبروني عن
شخصيه هذين الرائدين قالوا لك انا
متعاونين جدا شخصيتان لطيفتان
كانوا مؤمنين مع زملائهم الامريكيين واضح
لديهم حس علمي خاصه ريانه وهي وهي طبيبه
وباحثه علميه
علي ايضا هو رائد فضاء وهو نقيب طيار يسوق
طائره خمسه عشر لديه بكالوريوس في علوم
الطيران ريان اخصائيات بحث مختبرات لديها
بكالوريوس في علم الانجاب والهندسه
الوراثيه وتطوير الانسجه والذي خبره تسع
سنوات في مجال هندسه الخلايا الجزعيه
السرطانيه اذا يعني عالمه رائده فضاء
ستقوم كما ذكرنا باجراء 14 تجربه في
المحطه الدوليه
الفضائيه هي لحظات بالفعل لحظات تاريخيه
طاهر
نراها الان امامنا تكتب امامنا
المشاعر طبعا بالنسبه للاهل لمشاعر فخر
واعتزاز بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه كذلك
وبالنسبه لكل العرب هي مشاعر فخله واعتزاز
ان يشارك رواد فضاء عرب في البحوث العلميه
هناك يعني توجه توجه علمي جديد ربما
نستطيع ان نقول عنه كذلك من اجل استكشاف
الفضاء كنت اتحدث
عنها
حسين اذا سمحت لي يجب ان اكتفي معك بهذا
القدر مع اغلاق سياره تسلا ابوابها
وبانتظار ساعه الصفر سنعود اليك لتغطيه
هذا الحدث التاريخي بدون شك على شاشه
العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات